heute präsentierten
verteidigungsminister hans peter oszko
sozialminister alois stöger und
wirtschaftsstadträtin renate brauner in
der herz logistik schule in wien breiten
sie die neue initiative des bundesheeres
in kooperation mit was den wiener
arbeitnehmerinnen förderungsfonds im
zuge des neuen projektes mit dem namen
upgrade beraten das bundesheer und was
grundwehrdiener in wien
ziel ist es eine ausbildung die über den
pflichtschulabschluss hinausgeht zu
absolvieren
mit dieser bildungs und berufsberatung
soll den rekruten der einstieg in die
berufswelt erleichtert werden
neben dieser initiative bietet das
bundesheer auch lehrstellen an
derzeit werden rund 216 lehrlinge
ausgebildet davon 88 frauen das
österreichische bundesheer ist damit
einer der größten ausbilder im
öffentlichen dienst